we know that too many young men in our
community continue to make bad choices
and I have to say growing up I made
quite a few myself
sometimes I wrote off my own failings as
just as another example of the world
trying to keep a black man down I had a
tendency sometimes to make excuses for
me not doing the right thing but one of
the things that all of you have learned
over the last four years is there's no
longer any room for excuses
I understand there's the common
fraternity Creed here at at Morehouse
excuses are tools of the incompetent
used to build bridges to nowhere and
monuments of nothingness well we've got
no time for excuses not because the
bitter legacy of slavery and segregation
have banished entirely they have not not
because racism and discrimination no
longer exists we know those are still
out there
it's just that in today's
hyper-connected hyper-competitive world
with millions of young people from China
and India and Brazil many of whom
started with a whole lot less than all
of you did all of them entering the
global workforce alongside you nobody is
going to give you anything that you have
not earned nobody cares how tough your
upbringing was nobody cares if you
suffered some discrimination
and moreover you have to remember that
whatever you've gone through it pales in
comparison to the hardships previous
generations endured and they overcame
them and if they overcame them you can
overcome them too part of the way you
survive the stress of the White House is
being able to laugh with your team about
some of the crazy stuff that happens you
can't take yourself too seriously you
have to take the job seriously you have
to take your responsibilities seriously
but you have to be able to laugh at
yourself first and foremost in order to
be able to manage the whole thing you
just watch - amazing clips from Barack
Obama take the next three minutes to sit
quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]